it's incredible now Nate a lot of
anticipation for this halftime show with
Rihanna you got to sit down with her
what was that like
that's right I had the privilege to sit
down with Rihanna ahead of her apple
music halftime show to talk about her
longer way to return to the stage after
seven years here's a sneak peek
this is the NFL's biggest stage the
world will be watching
what was it like when you received that
call that you would be headlining the
halftime show it was so scary because it
was kind of unexpected to come back from
like zero to Super Bowl like that's kind
of nuts getting back to anything right
now has to feel worth it nothing is like
worthy of your time away from your kid
before my firstborn came I was good on
my own that's the way it was that
sounded like a lyric of mine it wasn't
lyrics
people want to know are there any
surprises I'm thinking about bringing
someone a word I'm not sure okay you can
tell me off camera when we cut the
cameras off
[Music]
now you can catch the exclusive sneak
peek interview tonight on NFL Plus at
8pm Eastern to sign up just scan the QR
code on your screen right now